-Our next guest is one-third of
the Grammy-nominated band Haim.
She received Golden Globe
and Critics' Choice nominations
for her acting debut in the
Oscar-nominated film
"Licorice Pizza,"
which is in theaters now.
Let's take a look.
-Listen, dad, he's an atheist
and an actor and he's famous!
-But he's Jewish.
-He was gonna take me
out of here!
Este, don't you even look at me.
Don't you even look at me.
You're always looking at me.
-Oh, my...
-What are you doing?
-I didn't even say anything.
What are you thinking, huh?
"I'm Este.
I work for mom and dad.
I'm perfect.
I'm a real-estate agent.
Alana doesn't have
her life together.
Alana brings home stupid
boyfriends all the time."
-I mean...
-I knew it.
-Please welcome back to the show
Alana Haim, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back!
I'm so thrilled
to have you here.
-Thank you for having me.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hi, guys!
-This -- I adored this film.
You were fantastic in it.
But before we move on,
I love that clip so much because
that is your actual family...
-Oh, yeah.
-...playing your family...
-Yes.
-...in the film.
And that look
your sister gives you --
that just seems like a look
she's probably given you
in real life.
-Oh, a million times.
-Yeah.
-I mean, I was
a very quiet baby sister.
I, you know, stayed in my place.
I never liked to rock the boat.
And I think filming that scene
was like 30 years of me
just holding it in,
and it just erupted after that.
-I guess that's a very unique
way of doing method acting is
just like, "You know, it would
be great if you could get
my actual family, and then --"
-Oh, totally.
-Yeah.
-It's my form of therapy.
-I wonder --
Because your sisters --
You know, I know they're
obviously onstage with you
all the time, and I know your
parents are musicians, as well,
but were you nervous when you
found out that your parents
were going to play
your parents in the film?
Because my parents
are here all the time.
They're great, but I also am
nervous having them.
-I was so excited, because my
parents are hilarious,
and I was just -- I mean, who
else could play my dad
other than my dad?
Really. I don't know
who else could play my dad
other than my dad.
Please let me know.
-And what was it like
the first time?
Did you watch the film for
the first time with all of them?
-We did.
-Okay.
-We all sat down
and watched it together,
and my parents -- The thing is,
they didn't have scripts,
so they had no idea
what the movie was about.
I tried to explain,
"There's waterbeds,
there's pinball machines,"
and they were trying to follow,
but didn't really understand.
And I'll never forget,
my dad, after the movie,
he just sat in silence,
and we all were like,
"Dad, are you okay?
Like, what are you thinking?"
And he stood up in front of all
of us and went,
"Este, actress, 100%.
Danielle, maybe.
Alana, no, no, she's not.
How did you know, Paul?"
He, like, literally could not
understand how Paul knew
that I could act.
He did not understand.
-So he was happy.
He was blown away
with how good you were.
-He was happy,
but he was just, like,
so mind-blown
that he never saw it.
He always wanted Este
to be the actress.
I'm sorry, Este. I'm sorry.
-That must --
I mean, I can't imagine.
It must be fascinating as
a parent to see somebody --
especially a parent who's
so supportive and has known
the many other talents
you have --
to see somebody else
find a talent
you didn't know
your daughter had.
That must have been such
a cool thing for him.
-It was -- I mean,
but he's really the star.
-He does steal his scenes.
-I think my dad
really is the star.
I mean, yeah, I'm going to
give it up to my dad.
You mentioned
Paul Thomas Anderson,
the director of this film.
That's the Paul
you were talking about.
What was it like when
he first called you to ask you
to do this role?
-I was super-nervous, obviously,
but I'm up for adventures.
I was like, "Come on,
give it to me.
I want to go. I want to go.
Get me in that truck.
I want to drive."
I was ready.
I mean, obviously, of course,
like, I was nervous,
but I was ready to go.
-And has this introduced you
to a new line of fans?
I mean, obviously,
you have fans as a musician.
Did people see this film
who maybe didn't know you
as a musician?
-I mean, you know,
I'm a, you know,
young, 30-year-old, single gal,
so when you're in --
[ Crowd cheers ]
Thank you.
So, you know,
like, what do you do
when you're a
young, 30-year-old, single gal?
You go on Instagram and, like,
maybe peruse your messages...
-Sure.
-...just to, you know,
dabble, see maybe --
-Yeah. You were in a movie!
-I was in a movie.
-Yeah.
And, funny enough, you know
who reaches out the most?
-Who's that?
-Orthodontists.
[ Laughter ]
The world, everyone is
concerned about my teeth.
I've gotten over 10 DMs
from orthodontists asking if
I need help and can they
please fix my teeth?
And I love my teeth.
-Yeah!
-I love my teeth and I have a
snaggletooth and I'm not --
I'm very proud
of my snaggletooth.
But the world of dentistry
is not pleased.
-Yeah.
Well, this breaks their heart,
because the worst outcome
from them is that someone can
succeed despite their help.
-I know. Exactly.
-But you did --
I mean, as a survivor of
orthodonture myself --
I had a long run.
I had about
five years in braces.
You did have braces.
-I had braces for four years,
and this is what my teeth --
I don't know if you can,
like, zone in on my teeth,
but this is what
my teeth look like.
Like -- Oh, it's happening.
It's happening. Come on.
Come on, come on.
-There we go. Those are great.
Those are very --
Those are the only teeth that
could have been in this role.
But you sent us
a photo of yourself
in braces to prove this.
And the best thing about
this photo --
Because it's a
birthday picture.
-It is. It's my 13th birthday.
-The best thing is what you got
for your 13th birthday.
-It was the best thing ever.
I got "The O.C." box set.
Look how happy I am.
"The O.C." box set.
My mom got it from Costco,
and it was the best day
of my life.
I cried, and you can see
I'm nervous even holding it.
I don't even think I opened it.
-Yeah.
This is, of course --
This film is about
the youth of California,
but it's the Valley,
and it's such a --
You mentioned, like,
you know,
it takes place in the '70s,
and it is, like,
waterbeds and pinballs.
You had to learn
how to drive a truck...
-Yes.
-...which I -- You know,
with all apologies to
Tom Holland, that truck scene
was the best action scene
in any film this year.
-You said it.
-Yeah, there you go.
I said it.
-I'm not saying a word.
I'm taking your word for it.
-What is the difference between
acting on film
that you found versus
being onstage?
Because, obviously,
that's a performance, as well.
-You know, it's funny.
When I perform with my band,
Haim, like,
five minutes before the show,
I regret my whole life.
I pace around.
I pace around, I go,
"What am I doing?
How do I --
Why do I do this to myself?
Like, I can't go out there."
I have incredible stage fright.
Like, I am so nervous.
And then the second that I step
onstage, there's like a veil,
and I'm just like a new person.
And filming "Licorice Pizza,"
I feel like five minutes before,
like, while we were
setting up a shot, I'd be like,
"Oh, my God.
I can't do this.
I can't do this."
And then Paul would call action,
and I'd be like, "I'm ready."
And it was the same,
and it was great.
-Are your sisters the same way?
Do you guys all have the same,
like, nerves pre-show
or is it different
for all three of you?
-I feel like it's definitely --
I mean, I never know
Danielle's pre-show,
because she doesn't talk.
-Okay, gotcha.
-And if you're a Haim fan,
you know what I mean.
No, I love my sister. No. No.
No, I mean, we all kind of
have our own things,
but we're so -- I mean,
we're incredibly excited
to go on tour.
I cannot wait to finally go on
tour and play our latest album.
-And this is the biggest tour
you've ever done.
-Biggest tour.
We're playing
Madison Square Garden.
-It's unbelievable.
-It's crazy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's unbelievable.
You might have to
give yourself 10 minutes
to pace before that one.
-Oh, yeah.
No, that's like a full 24 hours.
Full 24 hours.
-That's thrilling
and so exciting.
And you're actually --
You're going to do
something cool tonight.
-Yes.
-We are going to do
a giveaway to a Haim fan...
-Yes.
-...that is in the audience.
But you're going to go --
We're going to send you
to the audience to ask
a trivia question.
And here's the only thing
we'll ask is,
if you think you have
the answer,
don't just raise your hand.
Also stand up so it's easier
for Alana to find you.
-Yes.
-Alright, get out there.
-So, am I going?
-Let's go. Get out there.
-Okay, let's do it. Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Okay.
Hi, guys!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yay! Okay.
Wait. So, do --
Should I ask if there are --
if there is --
-Alright, yeah,
so, let's do this.
So, first, do you think you can
answer a question about Haim?
-You stand up.
What is your name?
-Annie.
Let's give it up for Annie.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Annie, I will ask you
this question.
Can you name three Haim songs?
-Yes.
-Number one.
-Yes. "The Wire."
-Boom! Got it.
Number two.
-"My Song 5."
-Boom! Number three.
-"Something to Tell You."
-Hey!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Annie!
-Alana!
-Okay, you got it!
-Alana, tell them what they won!
-I got to tell you what you won.
Are you ready?
-Yes!
-You won two tickets to any
Haim show that you want
on the "One More Haim" tour.
And wait. There's more, guys.
There is more.
Airfare.
And two nights in a hotel!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Annie...I love you.
I love you. I love her.
I love her.
-You guys,
give it up for Alana Haim.
"Licorice Pizza"
is in theaters now.
And for information on
the "One More Haim" tour,
visit haimtheband.com
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."